i'm about to watch and react to freaky
eaters hate the name of the show but
let's check out if there's any
nutritional value in it
20 year old amy is addicted to cola she
drinks on average 30 cans of cola all
day every single day wow 30 cans what is
it 12 ounces per can 30 times 12
is 360 ounces the 2 liter 64 ounces
that's basically five of those she
drinks five two liters a day holy moly
first problem right off the bat
tremendous amount of added sugars in
each one of these cans if i was to show
you before i pop up the image here how
much
actual
sugar is added to each one of these cans
it will blow your mind take a look
the most i had probably in a day is 50
cans i'm always drinking cola also not
good for your teeth and not good for a
lot of body parts also what else is in
cola caffeine that's a ton of caffeine
especially she's taking it at night
there's no way you're getting restful
sleep on that much caffeine i do get
tired a lot i don't have that much
energy because you're not sleeping well
we said that right off the bat you're
having too much caffeine too close to
bedtime and then on top of it every time
you drink a sugar it's sugar basically
every time you drink a cola your sugar
spikes your insulin spikes you get a
little crash recently amy had a serious
health scare when she discovered a lump
in her chest
which her doctor suggested might be due
to excess caffeine i think that you
drink too much caffeine and that is why
you have the tumor
hold up none of that makes sense to me i
think specifically with caffeine we've
seen studies that show both a protective
effect on breast cancer small rare
studies show that there's no change in
breast density
for premenopausal women like herself so
like i don't i don't buy that that tumor
or mass was caused by caffeine itself
i've just never heard of a case like
that could have contributed do it on a
healthy lifestyle yes but due to due to
no
wow that's a lot of gala
that's a lot of sugar wow
950 pounds of sugar is what you get in
your cola each year i don't think that's
understandable to the human mind but
they love it for the dramatic effect so
they could stand in the backyard and be
like whoa what we see right here is
you're already a pre-diabetic okay if
this is a fasting blood sugar the
glucose range puts her in their
pre-diabetic range of being at 115. also
i'm very very surprised that her
triglycerides are so low triglycerides
is what you would expect to be high in a
person who has uncontrolled or poorly
controlled sugar or a high intake of
sugar because the body stores sugar
through triglycerides in the blood but
the pre-diabetic thing should scare her
because while pre-diabetes doesn't mean
diabetes it is curable at that stage
once you become a diabetic you're
diabetic for life your risk factors
change 24 year old michael lives on meat
he averages up to 150 pounds monthly
that's equivalent to an astounding 1800
pounds a year the real problem with
overeating meat is your overexposure to
saturated fats if you're eating a hot
dog you're also consuming a lot of carbs
not only are you overeating
carbohydrates that have been bleached
therefore rapidly converted to glucose
and then rapidly stored as fat if you
don't eat it you're also consuming
saturated fat so all of that ends up
raising your bad cholesterol numbers
your triglycerides puts you at increased
risk for heart disease stroke anything
with cardiovascular
conditions in one day michael can put
away as much as five quarter pound hot
dogs a rack of ribs two steaks and up to
30 chicken wings red meat is a maybe
carcinogen like it's still not all the
way there it's like suspected but the
ones that are suspected are the
processed meats like the hot dogs like
the chicken wings so you want to avoid
those and eat those like almost get rid
of them totally but occasionally if
you're going to a football game and you
have a wing to me i think that's a
reasonable balance i'm a licensed
psychotherapist specializing in eating
disorders and addictive behaviors jj
virgin i'm a certified nutrition
specialist and a certified health and
fitness specialist this is a ridiculous
amount of chicken wings i don't like the
confrontational nature right away you
can't come in to a health care encounter
with that kind of attitude and hope for
good outcomes you're setting up the
encounter for failure right from the
start when you come in judgmental like
that so this would be dinner two and a
half pounds of meat right here two and a
half pounds of meat is a lot of meat
when we're talking about a portion of
meat it should be around six ounces
really like a fist amount
that is one
month worth of your meat consumption
where is this where is this being filmed
that they just jammed all of this meat
in there outside of being a cool visual
for tv i don't know how this helps
change his mind like if i'm him i see it
and go okay and it looks good you think
this looks good yeah that's what i was
gonna say like how do they think this
would turn him off we see this aa epa
ratio which tells you the risk of heart
disease what is this that they're
looking at this is an antiglidean
immunology blood test that tells you
whether or not you have antibodies to
gluten
what does this tell him about his meat
consumption these are not the lab tests
that i would show the test i would show
him is his ldl his triglycerides are
going to be quite high having really
elevated triglycerides puts you at a
risk for pancreatitis which could be a
life-threatening condition requiring an
icu stay you're 24 with high risk of
heart disease yeah what she was saying
and what they were showing all make no
sense her actual statement is fine he is
at higher risk but not for the reasons
that they just showed
victor lives on cheeseburgers and
cheeseburgers alone oh no i love burgers
he eats four burgers a day 28 each week
which is nearly 1500 burgers every
single year it's meant to be fast food
to be on the go every now and then not
to be something that is your primary
meal and if you develop type 2 diabetes
because of the the diet that you're
following one that is high in fat high
in sugar what ends up happening is you
have high risk of stroke and heart
attack yes but also high risk of
developing problems in your eyes leading
to blindness peripheral neuropathy where
you feel pins and needles or even lose
sensation in your fingers and toes and
that becomes such a problem that you
might have a rock in your shoe that you
don't even feel and then it leads to a
terrible infection that leads to an
amputation like think about the cascade
of events that were to happen
just from over eating burgers your whole
life
again with the cool visuals
i could see them in the in the
producer's room
let's get caught in some progress and
show you the truck and open them
[Music]
29 year old eric of cincinnati ohio is
addicted to french fries
i eat basically just french fries i you
can't you can't grow up to be a
functioning adult just eating potatoes
and french fries like you need vitamin d
ricketts is a legitimate concern for
people who don't eat or consume enough
vitamin d calcium
i'm very active i skateboard once a week
if not twice
because of his athletic lifestyle eric
hasn't become overweight and doesn't
think french fries are damaging his
health the way you look and the way that
your body's functioning is not the same
thing my cholesterol video that i made
talking about my blood test results i
was losing weight because i wasn't
eating a lot of calories but the quality
of the foods that i was consuming was
leading for my cholesterol to creep up
go real high and therefore put me at a
higher risk for having a stroke or heart
attack i may have looked great my abs
may have been coming in but that didn't
mean i was healthy weight is an
important factor of someone's health but
it's not the sole determinant of
someone's health status eric needs a
dose of shock therapy to really come out
oh yeah that's what he needs shock
therapy french fries
starch
salt
fat
this is the worst type of fat that you
can possibly eat
it's trans fat yeah trans fat is a big
problem and in some countries and parts
of actually the united states have
outlawed or reduced the amount of trans
fats that can be in food initially trans
fat was added to our foods in the 90s
but then we realized that it truly does
spike your ldl your bad cholesterol and
lower your hdl your good cholesterol so
it's like a doubly negative effect on
your health and we saw rates of heart
disease just absolutely skyrocket now
that being said very important point
here just because something says no
trans fat on it doesn't mean it's a
healthy meal
we wanted to show him the amount of
french we need a show
show the fries
get the boxes of the fries
this is ldl cholesterol it's the worst
kind and that's what this elevated
number is right here ldl being 110 is
slightly elevated for him so it's not
even that high but a 110 is not nearly
something that is scary very surprised
these blood work results are very
suspicious to me that he doesn't just
eat french fries or he's a very unique
anomaly
daniel has been obsessed with raw meat
for the past six years
he feeds his habit four times a week in
pound after a pound of raw beef eating
whole steaks pulled right from the
packaging if you look at cultures like
the inuit they were quite healthy and
they ate primarily raw meats they didn't
even eat that many vegetables they
didn't have it they lived in the arctic
and the tundra but what they did eat was
the entire animal so they got fiber from
the parts of the animals that we no
longer eat so there's a lot of problems
when people try and look at what other
cultures do without fully understanding
exactly what they do and how they do it
even raw chicken can somebody say
salmonella i have never gotten sick from
eating raw meat ever
i've been doing it for
six years now it just takes one time to
get really sick to get icu hospitalized
to potentially get a colitis so bad that
you need a colon resection and then need
to wear a colostomy bag to realize that
wow i probably shouldn't have been doing
that i'm as a doctor can't tell this
person what to do nor should i tell this
person what to do nor should i judge
what this person is doing but what i
could do is tell them the risks of what
i just said and then see like are those
risks acceptable to you and if so why
and if the person is cognizant and they
can understand and accept those risks
that's it uh you do have a parasite so
this looks like they gave him an ova and
parasite test of his uh stool sample and
they saw that there's a parasite but
they didn't do a taxonomy so they don't
know what kind of parasite it is and it
very clearly states that there's no
treatment that's even necessary if the
patient doesn't have symptoms or other
inflammatory markers that's an important
note there something else i want to
point out is if you eat undercooked
meats quite often you put yourself at a
risk of developing a tapeworm
undercooked port can lead to a cis
forming parasite that can actually lay
cysts in your brain you're risking all
these things
for no real benefit like just cook your
meat somewhat one more thing that's of
interest on this test
rotting protein that hasn't digested
sitting
in your gut
[Music]
they need to stop ordering these
these tests that mean absolutely nothing
like this show is so ridiculous my god
i've actually went vegan and keto before
click here to check out those videos and
learn about those diets and as always
stay happy and healthy which one you
clicking on
[Music]
you